(cris de joie)
(applaudissements)
- Sous les applaudisseme
ils foulent le sol canadien en
quête de paix et d'espoir après
des mois d'horreur.
Plus de 300 passagers ont
déposé bagages au Manitoba
en fin de journée. Heureux
et soulagés, ils ont pris
le temps de saluer leur
nouveau pays.
Pablo attendait sa mère
et sa soeur avec impatience.
Et ils ont été accueillis
rarararas ouverts. Marina a
confectionné des bouquets
de tournesols : symbole d'espoir
pendant cette guerre en Ukraine,
pour les remettre aux nouveauxa,
les rassurer dans leur langue
maternelle.
Ils trouv p p p p paix ici,
mais doivent maintenant se
construire une nouvelle vie.
C'est dans ce centre d'accueil
géré par le gouvernement
provu'u'u'u'u'ils auront de
l'aide pour trouver un logement,
un emploi et des services d'aide
à l'enfance.
Les défis sont nombreux,
et le gouvernement fédéral
le reconnaît.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND, vice-première
ministre du Canada
- La communauté ici, qui est
très forte, qui veut vraiment
accueillir ces gens. Et aussi,
que la collaboration entre
la province et le
va nous aider.
- Après Winnipeg, deux autres
vols nolisés doivent atterrir
au cours des prochains jours :
l'un à Montréal et l'autre
à Halifax. Mais, l'arrivée
massive de réfugiés ukrainiens
se fait toujours attendre.
Plus de 110 000 demandes
de visa ont été approuvées
par le gouvernement fédéral,
mais seuls 26 000 Ukrainiens
sont arrivés en sol canadien.ci,
Radio-Canada, Winnipe